a turning point us a communications
director Candace Owens was confronted by
protesters some wearing masks how well
courageous of them while she was walking
on the UPenn campus yesterday she was on
her way to give a speech here's what
happened Candice Owens joins us now with
more
Candace when I first met you we had a
very direct conversation I don't know if
you remember it
and I remember warning you that a lot of
people will hate you for being a
conservative and an african-american and
what I heard and saw there was F Candace
Owens F the police and Tifa protesters
first of all I'm sorry you had to go
through that no I appreciate I
appreciate the apology but I knew what I
was getting into when I got into this I
didn't realize how ugly it could get I
can't believe this is the tolerant left
but I think it's really important to
hold up mirror not to left us and to
expose them for exactly who and what
they are you know youyou actually said
something you know a couple things that
you said black Americans are being
misled by the Democratic Party under the
eight years of Obama minorities in
America were disproportionately
negatively impacted by his policies
eight years Trump becomes president we
have record low unemployment
african-americans Hispanic Americans
Asian Americans women in the workplace
youth unemployment we're breaking every
record imaginable the people that are
benefiting the most are are the same
people that will hurt the most under
Obama's policies will this begin to
resonate because I think you agree with
me on that and tell me if you don't I
agree with you 100% and here's what I'll
also tell you it already is
resonating that is why they are up being
there attacks on me because they think
that I am a part of the reason why it is
resonating in the black community I have
said this I said this on your show but
show back when I was first on it there
will be a black exit a blex it from the
Democrat Party in 2020 the black vote is
fully on the table and they are
petrified because they rely on the black
vote we are talking about moving at five
points and the Democrat Party is toast
these antics that you're seeing is
really their fear the updated KKK as I
like to call them and Tifa covering
their faces harassing me trying to get
me deep let's do this what I see you
step into these situations you knew what
you were getting into you feel the fear
obviously of it and do it anyway why is
this it seems like this is a conviction
inside of you that you feel passionately
why I do you know I spent a year and a
half running from these guys I've been
through so many kitchens at so many
events going through the basement going
through back doors and really hiding and
being fearful and I've changed my mind
so new policy I will forever and I
encourage all black Americans you have
the audacity thing for themselves walk
through the front door if ruby bridges
could do it at six years old in the
1960s I sure can do it in 2019 in a free
country of America being blessed by a
great presidency I really admire you as
a person who you are and the courage you
show and we wish you continued success
it's it's amazing to watch
congratulations thank you